[Music]
welcome everyone I've been working with
Julia for around four years doing also a
bit of development of Judea itself so I
hope to show you why I use Julia and why
you might consider also using Julia in
your projects I don't want to go into
details about Julia I will rather show
you things and ask you to think how
would you do such a thing on your
current technology stack and then I will
show you how you do it in Julia because
of course all the things you can do in
Julia you can do in at the other
language because Julia it's you can
think it over like you know you have are
you have Python and you have Julia so
every language can do everything more or
less but the question is how easy it is
to do this so I will talk a bit about
handing over large data about
parallelization about speed this is
probably the first thing you hear when
you hear about Julia and finally some
thoughts okay can we go into production
with Julia so first as I said several
warm-up questions I think of yourself
like me so that you use you have this
notebook I have there so it's like
standard notebook for writing he makes 8
mega gigabyte RAM some I 5 processor so
I have this laptop with 8 gigabytes Rams
and I have 2 billion floats somewhere
yes and I want to work on it like I
calculating mean this is what I will
show but in general anything to do a
histogram update this vector of two
billion floats and so on and so forth
he was probably Python R or whatever
think of how you would do this of course
what is the problem one float is one
eight bytes so actually this data set is
much larger than my RAM but I want to
work it as if it were it would fit in
so of course there are packages that can
do it in R or Python no problem
the difference in Judea is just it's
simply built into a language so if I
have a big such a big vector I simply
can map it to a file and it takes
actually two seconds to load it if I
wanted to copy it it would be 30 seconds
so it takes two seconds to load it and
then I simply start say okay calculate
me the mean and of course it takes some
time because it has to read all this
data and swap between memory and hard
drive but in general I work with this as
if it was a simply a vector in RAM and
it seamlessly built into the language of
course as I said in our you can do this
because you have a package for memory
mapped files but this is an extension
and you have to learn a new syntax for
the same thing you would do normally on
normal arrays so this is out of core
data but then there is a question okay
something you probably do on spark or
whatever distributed system you you
would use so for example take this is a
real case you have our know four years
of data each day each day is 10
megabytes this is high frequency trading
data from a stock exchange so the plus
is that the structure of every of those
CSV is the same and I want to do
standard things like filtering mapping
joints and so on and so forth I won't
show this here and of course I want to
use all my cars to do the computations
on this laptop I don't want to you know
make you know some huge installation of
whatever distributed infrastructure that
I would I want to calculate it on this
laptop that again I use the size because
the size of data is too big to finiti to
run so I won't show you the code but
Judea DB simply distributes this so
DB is for distribute bytes I tell Julia
that I have a directory where I have
those files and it processes and
distributes them across all my course
and all those stunts standard MapReduce
and so all things are they provided by
the language so we warm up to standards
think for any statistician doing
bootstrapping so you know that
bootstrapping paralyzes well very well
yes because you can actually every
iteration of bootstrapping can be done
independently
the problem with bootstrapping starts if
I want to distributed among many cores
that actually are know for example in
are you would have to copy the same data
onto every process so again if I have
large of all data of large volume very
fast I will run out of RAM actually and
that and the second question is how to
paralyze paralyze it for example in
Python I won't show you how you can do
this you could do this but in Julia
again it is pretty simple so I first
define an RI which I say that should be
shared among all processes actually when
I start Julia I start I tell Julia to
automatically paralyze to all the course
I have and then I have a comparison of
two bootstraps first bootstrap will just
run on one core and the second bootstrap
here will distribute Ematic distribute
among all the course I have so here this
is a standard bootstrapping procedure so
I want this cut is it in the detail here
the question is how does the one called
code differ from the distributed core
called simply I spawn workers and it
automatically distributes among all
cores so then this p PS vector will be
actually vector of promises as in
standard distributed calculation and
then
I simply felt those results and they
execute in parallel what is important
that this array with the original data
is certain all processes so there is no
copying off of the data so why is it
important and I think it is most nicely
summed up by the post of Giulia join the
petaflop Club you might have heard it
that this is the only high-level
scripting language which actually has a
successful real implementation in which
it reaches over one petaflop of
performance so if you would ask okay do
I have such a big Python installations
or are installations there are none
because in this at least as I know and
as you know the Giulia creators claim
because for example in Python you know
it very well you have Gil and you have
there are some ways around it but in
general it is a hard hard issue and in
Giulia it's simply inbuilt into the
language that you can distribute your
computations so this is a second
takeaway third takeaway very simple
actually I have added this this morning
I had some file not very big but it's an
issue of scaling some file of 15
megabytes of utf-8 string data of course
it could be not 15 megabytes but 15
gigabytes is no difference so I want to
read it into my memory what do you think
how much memory it would eat up
typical utf-8 file in Python it would
eat up around 30 mega actually this file
because this was actual fight it is 30
megabytes of memory in Julia it is 15
megabytes with some overhead a bit why
it's important because if you work with
a lot of data actually this will start
hitting you because of course
this is an example of utf-8 files if I
had pure ASCII data there would be no
difference or almost no difference but
for example if I have UTF data which
probably most of us will have to handle
someday then you start to see the
difference and again this is something
that simply inbuilt into into the
language why what is the reasons for the
difference if someone is interested I
can answer at the end of the of the
presentation so now the so those are
were the warm-ups so things that you can
actually do in other languages but
simply I believe that handling large
data and distribution of computation is
really simple in Judea because it's
inbuilt into the language but now the
issue about spit and the discussion will
be a very standard problem this is a
problem of pricing of Asian option so
the price of the Asian option is the
formula is not so not so important the
issue is here that I have to calculate
the average of some random stochastic
process over some period and decide
whether it's below or above the strike
price of the option so the standard
approach to evaluate such an option is
that you discretize ice disk discretize
the day the time into discrete periods
and here a standard approach would be to
use geometric Brownian motion to
simulate the move of the stock price and
then this is the recursive formula for
the price of the stock and then you
simply calculate the value of this of
this option but by average averaging a
lot of samples of such of such a
simulated process so let's start how I
my first implementation in Giulia
I simply takes those formulas and simply
translate them to code so this is
actually one-to-one mapping of my
formulation on the paper to formulation
the code so for example here I have this
X hat so X hat star 0 I have those
deltas so I translate it to those s
deltas and simply this is a very simple
looping code that you could write in
some other language probably also but
what I want to stress here that is
important this is a nuance but it's nice
that actually I can use any Unicode as
identifiers which I am a researcher this
is important for me because this is
something I would have in the paper and
I want a direct correspondence between
the paper and the code why because if
you look at a similar program in Python
doing exactly the same so here I have
for example this X hat so I have to
think that this is the same but actually
in Python of course it is this is the
coding Julia this is the code in Python
of course there are some differences but
in general the idea of the code is the
same so here is one special thing
probably we are at PI data so everyone
one day have used it I use number to
speed up the computations because so
this just-in-time compilation by direct
it tells me that number should compile
this Python code to machine level to
speed it up and I will show you what is
the difference between having and not
having this declaration on this function
in a second the only caveat is and
people who have used number probably
know two things about number first is
that not every Python code is a valid
number code and the second thing that
not all expressions in number and in
Python actually mean exactly the same
which means that in this case if I dad
at just by JIT it does not change
anything but in general if you want to
switch from Python to number you would
have to run the test to make sure that
your code actually produces exactly the
same values because it might not because
number in Python and are not 100%
compliant and it does not only mean that
it won't compile because for example
comprehension sin number won't compile
but even if their code compiles it might
produce completely different results but
so I have this annotation in this case
it gives the same result so this is not
a problem I want to focus on speed more
and to show you how this annotation
changes the performance of course I
could for example writing in Java it's
pretty much similar if I wanted to
switch to our actually I have a problem
because I implemented this looping
approach but this looping approach was
problematic because it was so slow that
actually I had to vectorize it and after
thinking a bit you can devise a
vectorizing approach to how to compute
this recursive process so this is the
code so instead of instead of instead of
doing a loop i allocate vectors and then
the cumulative sum which does almost the
same the only difference is that this
code compared to this code this code or
this code allocates a lot of memory why
because i have to allocate X and this
here cumulative sum as as some object in
memory and if I wanted to do a
fine-grained simulation actually this
could be quite a lot of memory but the
question is we can see that this code is
shorter can I write it in Julia yes you
can write almost the same in Julia so
very similar syntax
have only changed one thing here I
calculate cumulative sum of X and here I
also do it but I do it by updating
vector X by the results of cumulative
sum so here I will create a new vector
and Julia updates the old vector and I
will show you how big difference this
makes this is something actually this is
something not possible in there I would
allocate and the new vector anyway
whatever I would want to do so now the
question but decides of that the code is
very simple so if I won't do a
vectorized code actually you I can also
do it in Julia so now the I would say
the crucial thing what are the results
so here I so how it scales with M so how
fine-grained the computation is so this
juliek original julia code it's like
grants instantly almost every time
except for reading option where it takes
one second this vectorized code is so
this code is slower like two times
slower why because it has to allocate
memory now also the problem is that if m
were really big then I would ask have to
ask myself do I have enough memory but
but we can see that for the share
problem of allocating memory this goes
two times slower but now let's compare
this code in Julia the vectorized count
in R so it's like how six times slower
compared to this and like ten times
slower than Julia
so now Java is pretty fast but actually
not very good the interesting thing is
here of course everyone expected that
this code in pure Python will be slow
because it's to use user slopes and it
is really terribly slow in our it would
be even worse using number I can speed
it up
it's faster than anything except Julia
but it's still slower and actually as I
said it has two problems that not all
Python is supported by number and you
have actually to write tests anyway to
check whether your number code produces
exactly the same result so this is a
typical speed-up you can expect when you
you when you write your own custom code
because if if you use simply libraries
so if you want to call tenths of row
everyone talks about tenth of Laura so
it does not really matter if you call it
from our Python Judea or whatever every
language has bindings but if you have to
write your own code so you are not only
rep using someone's as work but you are
devising algorithms yourselves and
actually this is what I do at the
University and that's why I use julia
actually you will see a big difference
just an example from business this is a
pretty well-known use case from Aviva
insolvency to this is this is a process
of verifying even insurance company has
enough money to cover to cover the
potential claims that its customers
might want in such processes usually you
have to write custom code because there
are every situation is a bit different
and you have to run the right custom
code that calculates those risks so
Aviva reports that what they had earlier
was first of all using julia allowed
them to reduce the amount of code that
they had to write to do those randall
solvency to calculations and the second
thing is that the code anyway was around
twenty times faster so on large
deployments it means going down from 100
computers to five computers
and of course in the end they said that
because of all this they have also our
license footprint because for every
server it's not only server but you have
to buy software to it for it so this is
the case from not from Poland but
actually that it was last week
I have a case from Poland Ministry of
Health in Poland I don't know if you
know they they run quite a big project
of calculating forecasts and optimizing
the data about what Polish citizens will
what health problems Polish citizens
will have and then what should be the
optimal assignment of different fascicle
facilities around Poland in order to to
you know to have a matching of supply
and demand and so yeah so this is this
is the general project and they do
mostly they do a lot of it in our and
actually they came to me and they have
one of the problems they had is optimal
allocation of accelerators in
radiotherapy so they so what you have to
do you have you know you don't have
possibility to have this accelerator in
every city because they are very
expensive and actually you have to
assume that people will have to travel
to those accelerators in order to in
order to get the treatment so then the
question is given the limited number of
accelerators you can have what are the
optimal spots around the country where
you should put them in order to minimize
this travel time of the patients so they
had some code in our that did exactly
the same and it was like 500 lines of
code
and why how Julia allowed me to reduce
this code if anyone was doing
optimization in any language of course
not very simple optimization but more
complex problems in optimization so you
know that the real problem is that you
have to transform and this is what I
hear on every talk you'd have to
transform your problem into matrixes
so you you have you know objective
function must be a vector you have a
matrix of constraint of coefficients for
constraints and vector of right-hand
side for the constraints so actually you
have to do a lot of matrices and then
push it to a solver so and this was the
solution in our and the problem actually
ministry's problem was not that it was
500 lines of code but no one could
understand this code because they were
you know tweaking so for example matrix
B in fact in row 20 column 25 if it's
one that it means that something can in
if it's two it means that it's something
else in Julia for example for
optimization you have a jump packet
which is actually a domain-specific
language built on top of Julia which
means that if I have such a problem
actually I don't have to care about
those matrices I can write a high level
code that will be automatically by Julia
translated to this matrix language
problem so actually this code is 500
lines but I don't have to write them
because all those add expressions here
are macros that are rewriting this code
which is pretty simple to read for
example variable Y is a vector having
elements and it has to be integer and
non-negative and this package allows me
to rewrite all those expressions into
matrices but under the hood so I don't
have to do this myself
and actually I would say that if you are
doing optimization so even today
giorgia is a language of choice from any
other language you might want to use
exactly because of how you can write
optimization problems in Julia but of
course not everything is so nice about
Julia because there are no free lunches
so of course what what are my
experiences so on the good side let me
start with this is that if you are
writing your own algorithms then then
actually I think Julia is very good one
of thing is the speed but the other
thing and I didn't discuss it at all
today is how you can manage your code in
Judea because it allows you to structure
your code much better than for example
our scripts the second good thing is
that it has very simple bindings to more
or less anything you would want to use
for example if you want to interoperate
with our so you can call Julia from our
exactly act as if you would be using our
CPP if you ever used our CPP so the
package X our Julia is pretty similar
but it allows you to call Julia from
Earth so actually if in the past you
used our CPP because you had some hot
code which you needed to run you can
replace it if you know Julia you can
replace it by Julia and I would say that
writing code in Julia is simpler than in
C++ if someone has experience with the
bug in C++ code of course there is and
the inter operation is also simple in
other ways so there is a packet in julia
oracle j ji and jl and it simply allows
me to call any code any function of r
from julia seamlessly and the last thing
this is something i have shown here that
julia has very powerful meta programming
facilities which means that actually
it's not only that you
Julia itself is a nice language but
actually you can write your own DSL in
there you are working with in which
which will be bit on top of Julia so
what are the cons the first thing and I
think this is the biggest problem that
the language is still evolving which
means that it's not one zero version yet
so now it's version zero six we expect
that I would say in half a year will
there will be a version zero seven which
will be something like beta for 100 so
the expectation is that after zero seven
there will be no language changes at all
and just the period between 0 7 and 1 0
will be a period for bug fixing the
language but this means that if you
write a code today unless you know what
are the plans for the development of the
language because if I know for I know
more or less what what is going to
change so I know where I can expect that
some breaking changes mult happen but in
general if you upgrade Judea from one
version to another you might respect
that not everything will work exactly
the same because the language is not in
one zero version yet and this is
especially important in data science
packages so Georgia has something
similar to data frames but the design of
data frames is currently not stabilized
because people are working on making
data frames fast with nulls so this is
something that is inbuilt in our so this
is something similar we want to build in
something similar into Julia the issue
is that if you want to be fast so to
have something like this for also for
data frames this actually is a bit
difficult and this is a work in progress
but as I said if you are writing your
algorithms I think this those probes are
over overcoming those cones because
those changes are you know it's not that
the language totally changes it's like
simple single expressions change a bit
the last thing is something that is in
some application a deal breaker and this
is something that I expect also done in
one or two years or even five years will
be a problem that the difference between
Julia and Python or R is that Julia is a
compiled language and R in Python are
interpreted languages so if you use
number julia is pretty much more or less
similar to number yes so if you have you
use number in Python actually the first
time you run a function it has to be
compiled and the same thing is with
Julia so actually you use it right as if
it were a scripting language but under
the hoodie it says it has to do a
compilation which means that when you
have a short program and you started the
first time it has to be compiled which
can take some time so for example it's
not an efficient way to use Julia to run
over an 1000 times a very small program
per second because startup and shutdown
of the Judea environment will kill
performance it's much better to write
programs that still write that ran and
are listening to requests and responding
to requests for example using zmq is so
and in some applications this is a
problem and this problem probably will
not be solved and not at no time because
as I said it's not an interpreted
language but a compiled language and it
has to do compilation anyway it has to
do compilation exactly because we want
to reach this because the difference
between this speed and this speed is
that in Python after the line is
interpreted and in Julia it every line
of
program is compiled to machine code but
then you have the overhead of this
compilation which you don't have in
Python so this summarizes what I think
is interesting about Julia why it's
worth to have a look at it but also what
are the possible problems of using it so
thank you very much
and if you have any questions yes so the
answer is the following the the
languages that have comparable speed to
Julia in general are Seefeld Fortran of
course which means also C++ and just
just-in-time compiled lua so if you use
just-in-time compiler also it is of the
same speed as julia so in general you
can expect that a well-written code in c
julia or Fortran should be on the same
speed magnitude may be of course it is
like 10% or 20% plus of minus and
actually if you go to a julia language
website i don't know i don't have
internet on but on the first splash page
you will see a benchmark that as answers
exactly the same question but in general
you can expect that julia is the same
speed more or less LS c and just to
explain why because how julia works it
takes such a code the lower seat of
course as every other language then it
passes it to LLVM so like in swift and
then
LVM compiles it to the machine code that
is optimal for the machine you are
running the program on so actually if
you write if you read properly julia
code you can expect that there should be
not a difference to a properly written c
code because of course you can also
write C code badly but in general in the
end after compilation julia code is like
C code I mean the executable because of
course the language is different
okay so this is so this is a different
difficult topic because in general Julia
is a compiled language and it can store
those compiled versions of the of the
functions the problem is and actually if
you use Julia packages this is exactly
what happens so Julia packages use
precompilation so actually when you load
a package it's not compiled but only an
image of compiled package is loaded the
problem is that for example let's look
have a look at this code versus this
code in Java
I really compiled the code only once
why because I know exactly what types of
data I will pass to a Java function yes
because I know this is double this is
double and so on and so forth I can do
this in Julia but in general in Julia
you don't have to do this that's why we
use scripting languages I write it like
this but this means that if I pass for
example TS float and in the second call
I would pass an integer to this function
it would have to be recompiled because
julia actually will take notice that it
got a different type of data which means
that in general this is this what
yourself happens but the problem is that
if you have a complex function signature
you won't compile it to any possible
combination of of arguments and what
Judea package developers do they compile
it for the most often encountered
combinations of arguments so doing
something like this allowing other types
of data to be passed to the function but
if this new type of data is passed to
the function is it has to be compiled
just in time so you can do a pre
compilation but
is always that is that you will use such
a set of arguments to a function that it
will have to be compiled just in time of
course this just-in-time compilation is
not like one minute it's it's relatively
fast but in real time systems even you
know some time of compilation might be a
breaking problem
yes so if I understand you correctly dit
is what is done but in general if I you
know put a type assertion to every
expression here then I would lose all
the power of scripting language because
why we prefer Python to Java one of the
things is that we don't have to write
those doubles everywhere yes I simply
like this and and Python will choose a
proper function and this is something
that Judea can do of course here for
example I'm this is I put this just to
give an example here is a type assertion
so actually I tell Judea that X will be
a float but I did wouldn't have to do it
I can do this I could even do this for
every variable here and then I could
compile it and it would be compiled but
for example then for example in Java
implementation is that here I say it has
to be double and I would pass not a
double to a function and then it would
simply not compile and I would have to
write another signature for a function
that does not accept doubles and
probably does some conversions so so in
short this is a complex issue because
then you have in Giulia type generics so
actually you know you can have generic
types that are typed by other types and
in subjects and cases it gets complex
but in places when you can do
precompilation the comparable
precompilation
is done it can be stored and then load
from an image okay so thank you very
much and enjoy your lunch
you